those tears of nostalgia from Daniel
Radcliffe were surely contagious for
some of us but Emma Watson's laughter is
contagious to everyone during an
interview about Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows the typically totally in
control Watson who famously played
Hermione Granger found herself in a fit
of the giggles I was told that I wasn't
allowed to tell my friends that I had
the role that was basically impossible
for me cuz I was desperate to tell
everyone I knew while it's not clear
exactly what hit the star's Funny Bone
she struck to keep a straight face for
the rest of the interview and it's
nearly impossible not to laugh along
with her I'm so sorry it's okay can I
stop for just two seconds